making headlines Matthew Perry who was
nearly brought to tears with Diane
Sawyer watching himself painfully fan on
Friends
wait a minute I know that hat that's a
guy
[Music]
out of control he's going through too
much
but it's hard to it's hard to watch them
when I'm carrying weight it's alcohol
when I'm skinny it's pills I weighed a
hundred and 55 pounds on my way to 128
pounds
in his Memoir out Tuesday the now sober
53-year-old says he is most proud of
season nine that was shot when Matthew
was clean and he received his only
friends Emina oh are you kidding me this
is a night that we're going to celebrate
this is the greatest thing in the world
while Lisa Kudrow wrote the books
forward Matthew doubts his co-stars will
read the Memoir telling GQ quote why
would they read it I don't know fans and
addicts are going to care about this but
the cast is not tonight on ABC the actor
says they all knew about his demons but
Jennifer Aniston confronted him I
thought I was hiding it so well and she
said we can smell it or we can smell it
what doesn't Matthew know that he's all
right
[Music]
we weren't equipped we weren't
to deal with it
we've been through a lot of stuff
together I don't like talking about it
but
I know it's going to help
[Music]